love on the international space station
thank you okay you really annoyed who
everyone said love they were
yes
it's really hard to give a suggestion i
mean you know a few months about
someone's question israel palestine and
people didn't view them
[Music]
um
what person who booed what would you
suggest
over here wait there's
okay cool that person just went
i apologize it's been stolen by the
nurse okay and now we've got you love
the bachelor do you like irish man
sure yeah okay to be sure right so an
irish man if i have a bachelor right um
let's
[Laughter]
that's a great suggestion
love on the international space station
kangaroo no pouch irishman planned for
the bachelor but this
major stuff no no no no but you said
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i did not
[Music]
multiple strippers
[Music]
[Music]
okay love on the international space
station for the kangaroo pouch irishman
applying for the bachelor the beginning
of also pregnant tiger woods with a
single stripper these are some good
suggestions well done for a late show
you actually kind of kept your your
behavior doing well this then is is a
freestyle that's the right metaphor from
a spot based entirely no suggestions
it's not written it's not prepared uh
it's not rehearsed and uh it will be if
the [ __ ] little
connector goes in and don't worry you
won't be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle-class white
british boy to be
[Applause]
[Music]
properly
[Music]
[Applause]
sat there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pregnant dependent on working in the
club yeah she's got dependents now why
because the world was really daddy the
relationship was difficult
so badly she's like actually divulging
to tiger it's like i've never cried so
much in my life for a little bit still
it's kinda long he goes home he puts on
a sad song he's like oh i love the tunes
of didgeridoo australasian music thinks
about a kangaroo
[Music]
[Music]
i really get what i'm deserving the
kangaroos found in my super your plastic
surgeon that's so incredible he can't
resist he says bruce do you want a
brazilian butt lift he's like no any job
on your mammary glands because they
produce
[Music]
lady at the back probably wearing a
dress with slight love and you were like
nah look above going up there when push
comes to shove you can push you away and
you float for days it's like that one
with sandra bullock amazing
they wanna reconnect get a kiss here i'm
going on a little show on the tv and i'm
having here got a lot of girls to date
when i'm on the bachelor i wanna get
fiance that's my wish but they tell me
down why cause i'm irish and if you're
from jobling don't touch me i'm just
saying they wouldn't get on the show
cause they're goddamn ugly
you